Donald Trump is known for his bluster
but his threat to obliterate North Korea
caught many observers off-guard the
United States has great strength and
patience but if it is forced to defend
itself or its allies we will have no
choice but to totally destroy North
Korea Trump then slammed Iran saying
it's a rogue state whose chief exports
were violence bloodshed and chaos he
called the deal with Iran which saw many
international sanctions dropped in
exchange for cuts in the country's
nuclear program one of the worst the
u.s. ever made Trump also stressed that
national governments needed to realign
themselves rather than turn to the
international community for help in
other words America first in America the
people government the people rule and
the people are sovereign I was elected
not to take power but to give power to
the American people where it belongs in
foreign affairs we are renewing this
founding principle of sovereignty in the
past Trump and denounced the United
Nations as a bloated money wasting
bureaucracy a theme he continued in
Tuesday's speech we also thank the
secretary-general for recognizing that
the United Nations must reform if it is
to be an effective partner in
confronting threats to sovereignty
Security and Prosperity too often the
focus of this organization has not been
on results but on bureaucracy and
process
the US president also called for the
world's nations to take a bigger role in
promoting security and prosperity in
their own regions
[Applause]